ENFORCEREAD A PORTION OF THINIH
HAPPENED.
SAID ANIE
AFTEDICAL IN DURING
POLICENTAC. JIMENEZOUT.
INSTEAD, THIS IS A BLA UP ENTEN
SUSPECT INTO HANDCUFFS ANDED APU
MEDICAL DISTRESSAVE BEEN GEORGE
FLOYD IF THAT T ACCOUNT WAS THE
ON WHAT HAPPEN
JOINING US NOW LEGALANALYSTS, C
LAW ENFORCEMENT ANALYST AND TOP
P HILADELPHIA AND
IN OPOTIME,
OFFICER NOCING? IS THI
THE CHARGES AREH
HIGHEST, NORMALLY 40 YEARS A
25 YEARS AND TEN YEARS BUT
BASEON CRIMINASTORY.
YOU'RE LOOKING AA PRESUMPTIVSEN
DYMICER LE PERSON AN
INTG THIS T THE
CONSIDERATON THE SENTENCING
GURANGE
THGRFA
DECIDE WHETHER IO TO
M MAORS MUM OR TTH
STALONG THAT.
HT WEEKS E JUDAKING THAT
SENTENCE AND WTHAT W.
EAG
PRESENTENCE REPORT THAT
TALKS TO CUVKS IN LIKE REMORSE,
WE ALWAYS HAVE TO HAVE A WAY T
IS SENTENCE
EBY BANTT THIS
>> WELL, DEPENDS WHEN YOU'RE
IF YOU HADA YEAR AGO,
WOULI EXPECT IN 11 MONTHS
THERE TO BE GUILTYN IN
TWO, I'M NWHATOULD HBEENN SEEIN
LAWERENG ABOUT
NGE AND EN HOWE EN AS
S KEPTALKINGBOWAS VERY STROND
THE DEFENS
AND WHEN HEA
VET  IN'T EXPECT
FOCHICTODAY.I DIDN'T FORE COUNT
IM TO SIFT
WHVERDICT THRVENIN
QUESTIONS AND DI SM Y ARGUMENTA
JURORS, THAT TO ME WAS A SIGN
E WEREILT
A T COURSE, YOU
SE THERE ARE
ACTIONA.VERDICTST BEFORE IN BIGO
HE GOTCT
L
YOU NEVER KNOW.
GIVEALORS, IS
FOR YOU SEEING WAS SO STRONG.
CHAUVIN OUT T  LIKE?
HA GEORGE EELED OF IN
DIGNITY
DERR
DEREK RDPROCESS OFAL AND DUE
PROCESS, WE WOULDN'T BE
DAHINK ABOUT ALL IT ULD HAVE TAE
WE ARE RIGHT, ALL IT
HAVE TAKEN, THE IDEA OF LEADING
S NECK, NOSSING UR
TNECKRECHAW. B WHAT U TALKED BM
JIMENEZ SAID.
IF WE DIDN'T HAVE THIS
VIDEOTAPE, THIS WOULHAOME
EMNAMELESS
SOMEBODY'S NAME TH
THE RSG THAT
.
ME SS NAME WASGEER
14th,
THIS BEGAN ANDITH
SOMEBODY HAVING THE ABILITY
SAY THE OFF T
S DE I
U GEE
OPPORTUNITY LAW.
>> CHI AMENTLIKE T INITIAL STATT
FR HOW DOEET
WHO DECIDES THAT?U
>> W U, THAT'S HAPPENS.
A US THE F IS CE
R GOING TOUP BEI
ACTUAL STORY.
YOU KNOW, FAE GOING TO
WHICH THAT'S WHY YOU HAVEATION
OCCURRED IS A MISTAKE BECAUSE U
INVESTIGATION INTO THE MATTER.
Y OBVIOUSLY SPENT AR  ENFORNT Y
. ANAT
DID YOU TAKEY FROM TODAY?
>>L, KW,O
E PROSECIO
G ARGUMENTE SAID
METHING THAT REALLY CKE
AICE  A PROPOLICE TRIAL ANDINO
DUTY. OF
OFFICERS TERY DAY
WITH HONORS SUPPORTS
ITRTS WHATHEY DO EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
EYEES LIKE
DEREK HE DEPARTMENT.
>> BUT YOU BELIEVE THE SYSITO CT
S TO BE REFORM. IS
NO, THIS IS ONE E  MISTAKEF  SI
INCIDENT WST TCONT TOWARDS REFO.
POLICING.UST IN
THE ENTIRE
ST REVIEWED.E REVIEW OF THE
EE
DECADESS
THERE.ICE BUDN
SM.O YOU AGREE WITH THAT?TH OF
YOU DON' WH RSUIT
OF JUSTICE BECAUSE Y'V
ISMP
WHAT UNDER LINED THIS SE?ND V.
THE REASONSS OF FORCAND
W WE JUDGET E LENSR, THIORY  HA
LARGELY TEST BT OFARO
OVERCOME THE HURDLE TO SAY YOU
GIVE AN OFFICER THNEE DOUBT BEC.
WEAVE  MORNING
AR WAS 9
IF YOU JGEER  EXCESSIVE FORCE CS
AND EXTEND THEENEFITF
UBNGHEM CARTE BLANCH
HE
AND AWAY THAUMVEL
DOWNPOUR. O YOU SEE ,, I MEAN
CHAN COMING FROM THIS?
>> IF GEORGE
IDRARED IN
E BRAINSEVAMIC
SAOTH .
IE THE PROPER
VERDICT WAS REACHED IN MY VIEW
YORD
I'M ONE OF T PEOPLE.A SIGH OF R
YOU WORR PAR SOM'T
POINT TO THAT SA
. ONE B
CANL WITH BAD ALET
NOW THAT THE T I
THE SUSTNSD THAT
A STRONG CUDD
THE GUILTE
CASE DOESN'TM TO BE RIGHT
EVEN THOUGH ITT
NOTENN CAHI
S IT SPECIAL.
WHS ABOUT THE SYSTEM,
THIS VERDICT SHOULDN'T
SEEM SPECIT WAS
REALLY PREORDAIN IN MYIFIT WAS N
THE FACTS OF THE C
AND A HALF
TEEORGE
WE SHOULD TAKE RIEHE
VERDICT BUT I HOPE IT DOESN'T
SLOWE DOWN.
>> CEF I MEAN,
IMPORTANATS IS JUST,YOU , THE FN
ARGUMENT YOU'RNG, THIS ARE
MAT MAJORITY OF POLICE ARE
NOT LI DEREK CHAUVIN
WAY.
SBIGGER THAJUST POLE FICERS.
M KW,F
E A LOT OF BADS ING ONHET SOMEP
TREE.
E E SYSTEMIC ISSUES THAT  ADDRE
THE PRESIDEN NATIONA F        RI
-- LISTEN, WHEN WE LOOKED RIGH
INTO SOME THAT NEVERAWRABEEN DE
POLICE OFFICER DO ANYTHING WRONG
AND IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO TAKE
ARY ACONST ALIOME ETHERW
ENEM I
.I'M TTLE OVE YEARS AND
AND WE HAVE TO LOOATO.
WE HAVE